yes well lemme include it in a video
I would imagine better so a couple of
days ago John and I were in a car with
Maureen Johnson and the lady was driving
got a call on her phone boop boop boop
not handy found regular phone and we
could get a hear what was coming out of
the ear piece because it seemed a little
cell phone computer Lee allowed
sometimes and we heard the person she
was talking to say that there were 16
people waiting for us already at the
East Grand Rapids brenston Kent each
library and we were like yeah all right
16 people that's awesome and then she
finished up her phone conversations and
she closed it down and she said guys
there gonna be 16 people there and we
were like 16 people that's awesome and
she's like no no no no no no no no no no
66 0 60 and we were like 16 16 and by
the time we got there it was like 75 by
the time we left it was 97 97
nerdfighters in one very small room it
was more interesting so as you might
imagine the event was covered from
multiple angles
there were lots of cameras there are
actually some fairly prominent youtubers
there I was like resident likely should
be up here with us but since there was
so many cameras I figure I'll provide
multiple angles and I'm able to do this
with the help of the people in the
sidebar footage I was able to rip off of
YouTube
with permission so here's the entrance
oh thank you oh my god that's crazy
[Music]
that is completely crazy
Corrie introduces Rosalie like a tunnel
right okay Cory go ahead there's
something evil laugh we are completely
unprepared for a lot of people have
anything we thought it was gonna be like
ten times the video cameras like ready
for you like Oh John Green angry
Morgan Johnson secret sister Maureen
[Applause]
wow wow wow that's a lot of people and
I'm really glad that John's good of that
kind of stuff because I wasn't really
sorry about that
and here's possibly the most important
thing that happened of the night to the
inaugural Maureen Johnson happy dance
three different angles thanks to all the
nerdfighters who got their cameras out
fast enough that's what happened first
John read a little bit of Paper Towns
and then Maureen got a little bit of
sweet scarlet which is her new book
which you could buy in the sidebar right
now and then thanks to Alex who also was
linked in the sidebar I was able to play
some songs we were like Oh Hank didn't
bring his guitar and Alex Q's videos
I've seen before I was like uh yeah
mines in the car I brought it just in
case I was like really that's convenient
but I didn't it was okay with the way
they were fine it was very comfortable
the fact that everyone like knew the
words I asked you deathly hallows it was
kind of like uh being a rock star except
in a library full of nerds in a room
that contained more awesome than any
concert hall ever has in history made me
I don't want to cry a little bit I also
kinda wanted to cry when they all sang
me happy birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
that a step I'm not nerdfighters well
some summer nerdfighters put all over
librarians the reason we were actually
able to go to Grand Rapids John and
worried 9 was because the Michigan
Library Association was having a
conference and they wanted us to speak
at it which we did and which was really
fun but we would not have been able to
go there or do this with other Michigan
Library Association so thank you so much
to all who worked so hard to organize
this especially Corey thank you thank
you thank you
we're obviously not the easiest people
to work with but I think that you had a
good time we had a great time so thank
you so much additionally it helped us
realize that we kind of want to do this
more and so we're thinking about doing
it more but the only way that we'll know
where to go is if you go to eventful
calm and there's a link in the sidebar
as you might imagine among all those
other things there's another one in the
sidebar to eventful calm if you go there
and you request our presence in your
city that my friends will help you see
us and it will help us to you and it
will be awesome please do that a lot of
you already have but please do that as
you can definitely tell have done over
on this video that I've been granted
amnesty due to the fact that there was a
montage there were actually several
montages through the video so John I had
a great time and I'll see you soon
ha